also for our investigators they've been
busy today a family in Las Vegas
outraged after the woman who who killed
their loved one got what they call just
a slap on the wrist it was certainly an
emotional day and eight news now
investigator Kyle Payne was the only
reporter in the courtroom Kyle what
happened guys manchika good joint was
outside a convenience store near Owens
and H when another woman bludgeoned her
to death it was a gruesome crime and
today good joints family says justice
was not served
we couldn't give her a decent burial
because of the way my baby looked Roslyn
Byron in District Court pleading with
judge Jacqueline Bluth not to let this
defend in Vanessa Harvey out of jail so
quickly so under this charge the maximum
National pair is four to ten years and
that's what she got four to ten years
for killing 42 year old machika good
joint with this metal pole but the law
of the family says just isn't enough in
this case the justice system is just
really really screwed up that's
ridiculous Teresa green is another of
the victim's relatives she is left to
raise good joints to youngest children
that's nothing for life not just for the
media face to face it only made the
family angrier to watch Harvey who
seemed to be smirking in court while the
victim's family pleaded for justice she
came into courtroom smiling she don't
have no remorse she didn't have anything
to even say period how to do nothing
you're under arrest for obstruction
right now all right that's your identify
yourself you failed for yourself Harvey
had a lot to say the night she was
arrested covered in blood up against a
bloody Street Post while machika good
joints body lay lifeless outside this
convenience store I don't care about
a thing right now I would never give my
baby back
because she's being credited for a year
and a half time served awaiting today's
sentence